an american werewolf in london wasn't
just a hit with audiences it also
inspired the king of pop to make one of
his most iconic videos keep watching for
more inside information on this horror
comedy classic
can i have a piece of toast
in an interview with indy wire director
john landis described how he began
working on the screenplay for an
american werewolf in london in 1969 when
he was still a teenager while serving as
a production assistant during the
filming of kelly's heroes in yugoslavia
landis and a co-worker were traveling
down a road when they witnessed a gypsy
funeral the recently deceased man was
wrapped in garlic and buried feet first
in an abnormally deep grave with the
hope that the precautions would prevent
his rising from the dead i kept thinking
what if he did get up the experience
inspired landis to start writing a
horror story and it didn't take him long
to finish the script convinced that an
encounter with the undead was one of the
most terrifying things he could
experience he was intrigued with the
idea of how an 18 year old like himself
would deal with such a horrifying
situation however the idea did not
garner much interest at first so he was
forced to stow it away for more than a
decade over the course of that decade
landis made a name for himself with a
string of well-received comedies that
included the kentucky fried movie animal
house and the blues brothers with his
career established the director was
finally able to make his werewolf film
in 1981.
even though the funeral rights that
inspired landis were driven by a fear of
zombies he wanted to go in another
direction for his film he later
explained that he picked werewolves
because of their international appeal
with stories in just about every culture
landis was also more interested in the
complex nature of the werewolf character
for the featured monster as he later
explained i really took from the lon
chaney wolfman picture because what that
added was this element of tragedy
historically people in france and wales
were burned to death for being
werewolves or witches and the film made
it a curse where the wolf man himself is
a victim all this history and complexity
means werewolves are never too far from
the popular imagination although landis
had to wait years before he could get
american werewolf and london made it
arrived at a real moment for the beasts
the howling wolfen and full moon high
were all released the same year nice
doggie
good boy john landis wanted poor weather
throughout the movie so he scheduled
filming for february and march this was
especially difficult for lead actor
david naughton who had to run around
without clothing outside in the freezing
cold in an interview with the sf site
the actor recalled that's rather
difficult to do because it's cold and
you've got no shoes on and i don't jog
in bare feet in any weather even back in
california while the production was set
up in a small town in wales there was
such bizarre weather that at one point
it snowed sleeted rained and had periods
of clear sunshine all in the same day
landis always wanted the right look even
if it was very uncomfortable for the
actors as notton recalled we were in
england and it's not raining so they
made rain why would you make rain in
england we're out there on the moors
with these rain machines it was so cold
the rain machines were freezing
renowned makeup and special effects
expert rick baker put in meticulous
detail to create the american werewolf
visuals that are still admired today
horror site bloody disgusting later
recounted the many months of prep work
for the transformation scene when the
audience first sees naughton's painful
and frightening metamorphosis into a
werewolf when baker met david naughton
for the first time he knew what he was
going to put the actor through and said
quote i feel sorry for you to get into
his werewolf makeup knotten left for
work at 4 30 am and sat still in a chair
for 10 full hours until he was ready for
filming the process he described as
being similar to a long flight that
never actually landed the actor
reportedly complained so incessantly
that during a panel landis and baker
once told him to stop making it sound
like he survived torture
you're not real
i don't be a pets david co-star griffin
dunn's experience was also unpleasant
but not as bad as naughton's when
talking about baker in the process dunn
later recalled i hated the makeup i
loved baker he made the six hours
bearable the makeup's on and then it
constricts and then it pulls on your
skin and then it has to be loosened up
you have people fussing with you you
want to pass out from the fumes
david naughton may have been vocal about
the torturous process he had to endure
but there's no doubt that he respected
rick baker's impressive techniques as
did the rest of the film community not
only did baker win an oscar for his
revolutionary makeup effects but as
noted by the academy of motion picture
arts and sciences he was the first to
ever earn an award for an entirely new
category that was created in 1981 for
his craft american werewolf in london
continued a partnership that landis and
baker struck up on the director's first
film 1973's schlock when both men were
barely in their 20s even back then
landis was pitching baker on his
revolutionary transformation scene
telling him he wanted the film to quote
show the pain it paid off and remains
one of the most memorable scenes in
horror movie history
[Music]
it may have been cheaper to film the
movie in the uk but john landis ran into
some serious problems including a major
casting issue landis wanted to put
people of color in the film in order to
reflect the cultural diversity of london
in real life but it was hard to find
actors that were members of local unions
and also people of color still the
director didn't take no for an answer
landis spent much of the production
fighting to show the quote multicultural
nature of the title city and kept
fighting until he got the faces he
wanted on screen
while landis was making sure all the
necessary steps were taken so that the
film could be made in the united kingdom
the british government informed him that
he needed four work permits for himself
rick baker david naughton and griffin
dunn things got testy when the director
later learned that despite the
requirement the government didn't want
to give out more than three permits
while naughton landis and baker easily
got the permits the local actors union
initially prevented dunn from working in
the country because it preferred the
role to be played by an american actor
already living in the uk again landis
remained firm threatening to change the
location of the story to france and
modify the screenplay accordingly as a
sign of how serious he was landis even
scouted possible places to shoot in the
rival country instead according to total
film in the end landis hardball tactics
worked and dunn was awarded his permit
france lost the first round but when an
american werewolf in london received a
long delayed sequel in 1997 landis
threats proved inspirational an american
werewolf in paris moved the story's
action across the english channel
the tense climax of american werewolf in
london takes place at piccadilly circus
which is an often chaotic intersection
bustling with traffic in order to film
scenes of the werewolf rampaging through
the crowded area landis needed to prove
to the right people that he could pull
it off without shutting the whole place
down landis already had success working
with the chicago police for the blues
brothers which seems likely to have been
useful when approaching officials in
london after inviting 300 police
officers to attend a free screening of
the blues brothers the director was
allowed to film at the piccadilly circus
the first time that had been allowed in
15 years according to dread central to
help seal the deal landis recreated the
whole area on a stage so the crew could
rehearse and get it perfect before
filming actually began
for the movie soundtrack landis wanted
to highlight the werewolf themes with
songs that had the word moon in the
title he managed to get the rights to
three versions of blue moon van
morrison's moon dance and creedence
clearwater revival's bad moon rising all
songs that fit the theme the first
rendition of blue moon used in the film
is bobby vinton's followed by sam cooks
and then the version performed by the
marcels landis may have succeeded in
securing those tracks but he failed to
secure others he wanted very badly
possibly on the top of that list was
moon shadow by cat stevens who had
recently converted to islam and had some
objections not only was stevens opposed
to having his work associated with
supernatural themes but he didn't want
any of his songs featured in a movie
that was rated r similar to stevens bob
dylan refused to give permission to use
his version of blue moon and elvis
presley's rendition was simply
unavailable to anybody
see you next wednesday is a short adult
movie within the film that the american
werewolf crew actually made
landis originally planned to have his
hero visit a cartoon theater in london's
piccadilly area because he'd seen such
venues in the 1970s by the time the
1980s rolled around and he returned to
london though all the local theaters had
begun showing adult movies lantis
changed the script to reflect the local
landscape and see you next wednesday was
one of the first things shot for the
film
good movie
see you next wednesday is playing at the
piccadilly circus cinema near the end of
an american werewolf in london when the
protagonist is confronted by the undead
specters of the innocents he slaughtered
in his beastly form
john landis wanted an american werewolf
in london to be a true horror film that
terrified audiences but he was careful
to make sure it was also tame enough to
secure an r rating meaning the sex
scenes weren't too gratuitous and he had
to lose a shot showing a piece of toast
falling out of griffin dunn's ripped
open throat there were other gory shots
and scenes that landis did film but
ended up removing before the theatrical
release a longer scene showing the
werewolf brutally killing a group of
three homeless men was also taken out
because there was such a negative
reaction from test audiences landis got
his r rating but he later admitted that
he regretted toning down the horror
an american werewolf in london took some
time to acquire its cult status but it
had some major fans right away including
pop star michael jackson who liked john
landis and rick baker's work so much
that he asked the filmmakers to make the
music video for his song thriller in
1983. jackson reached out to landis
directly and had just one major request
at first he wanted to turn into a
monster himself in the video landis and
baker were quickly on board for the
collaboration with the king of pop along
with fellow american werewolf veterans
producer george folsey jr and landis
wife costume designer deborah landis the
team also included cinematographer
robert painter and composer elmer
bernstein making thriller a mini
american werewolf reunion the pop star
was certainly pleased with the results
he had landis direct another one of his
music videos black or white in 1991.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]